So, the first concept we will learn
in full tolerance is dependability. Dependability is
a quality of delivered service, meaning a
characteristic of delivered service, that justifies relying
on the system to provide its service. So pretty much a dependable system
is one that provides the service in a way that makes us expect it to
provide it correctly and in a dependable way.
Now, the service actually has two definitions. One
is the specified service, which is what the
behavior of the system should look like. And then
we have delivered service which is actual behavior.
This is the behavior we actually got out
of the system. So we could say that
dependability is really about can we expect the delivered
service to match the specified service. Can we get
what we are supposed to be getting from this system.
Now of course the system has some components which
are called modules. So these are not components like transistors
and so on. These are the kind of largest
components of the system. So for example, a computer system
will have a processor and a memory and so
on. Each of these has components of its own and
so on. And for each of these modules
we can specify some behavior that it should be
ideally getting. So each module has some sort
of ideal behavior that we will want to expect
from it, but of course real modules will
maybe not always exhibit this ideal behavior. So when
we talk about things that make the system
not be dependable, we're really talking about modules deviating
from specified behavior and that causing the system to deviate
so that the delivered service no longer matches the specified service.